can you take us through the sponsorship
process sure each one was different you
said just six sponsors no six revenue
streams we have I think of Lee's nine
spots right I'm sorry
okay so sponsorship is different than
product placement okay
product placement you basically you know
you want to have company X in your film
and so you have to clear it to be able
to have that that's their IP their
trademark their logo in your in your
film and so but if you're good at it you
could get a lot of free stuff out of it
I've had I've had directors that I've
worked with in the past like challenge
me like can you get me this can you get
me that and and generally oftentimes I
can get them crazy stuff
and but it's a matter of knowing how to
do it and you have to know what you're
asking for and you need to give them a
reason why you're asking for it and you
need to make sure you have your
contracts buttoned up and everything
else as well
now in terms of sponsorship it's a
matter of making sure that they know
that there's going to be an audience for
your project and so that's one reason
why you build audience early on and with
that being said you have to make the
sponsor as comfortable with the project
as possible
and be very transparent about what
you're doing you know brands will not do
not like when you bash their brand
obviously that's not gonna even work I
mean we've even had brands say that they
have to be there protag and it's not the
antagonist you know and so like it gets
to be a little bit a little bit tricky
on certain things but the sponsorship
process is you're creating a deck you
know and where and how their identities
going to be seen what their activations
are going to be above and beyond just
the picture itself in terms of are there
going to be a lot of events they're
gonna be premieres is there gonna be you
know you know anywhere where they could
you know attach themselves to you have
to provide you so all this like kind of
like packages for the sponsors and so
it's work it's a lot of work to be able
to to get
but we were able to raise oh gosh about
20% of our budget came from sponsorship
Wow and how are you choosing which
sponsors to approach research and what I
want I guess you would say lately like
literally like her billboard I first
went to local businesses because we want
to feel authentic and so it only made
sense for us to show off local
businesses and then after that we
green-screen the billboards in in the
film so we can actually change out them
all if we go to like India we could
change out the billboards to Hindi you
know French the same sort of thing
and again just thinking about like our
entrepreneur think about like a
businessperson and but we did that so
that the brands could then see the
content so they would okay it you know I
mean so so that's kind of like another
reason why to is to try mitigate as much
risk as possible so you find some brands
that you think would be a good fit and
then you're calling them you're sending
an email I always call first and it's a
matter of the then is tracking down the
right person EDP speaking to you because
every company is different you know some
of them it's a brand manager some of
them is to see is this CMO some of them
is the they have a sponsor coordinator
some of them are you know their movie
development people they for instance
some companies use announce a third
party like I think it's tier three and
like a bunch of other ones that they use
as a clearinghouse for thing so they
then have to talk to them it's a lot of
legwork a lot a lot of legwork but I've
been doing it for so many years that
like I like this is one gentleman those
at Lafayette College at a it was a
junior in college and wanted to intern
from you over the summer and I'm like
this is what you're gonna be doing and
he's like how am I gonna do that I'm
like I'm gonna teach you I'll tell you
what you need to do and he would come
back with me with law questions all the
time and everything else and by the end
of the summer like he could be hired by
any major studio because because it's
your scribe
once you've already established who the
brand manager is maybe you've had a
phone call maybe you've sort of made
this like initial contact you're sending
this is it a pitch deck oh yeah you put
a deck and then you actually even try
and show how their brand is gonna be
seen in the content as well and then you
give them how much time to kind of look
at it what's like the protocol a week a
week start badgering and and they are so
associated yeah okay yeah everything is
so different like I could have had some
major brands on our billboards they
didn't want to necessarily give me money
but they would have done it and trade
for a lot of exposure and I walked away
from those deals
why because I felt like my project of
more value and I just I just I don't
know like like in retrospect I wish I
would have for a couple for two of them
quite honestly but I made the wrong
decision straight up okay Alan wants to
say like like and and cuz we could have
done some fun things but the same time
it might have limited us from other
things and also choose one of them was
did I want them to be a part of the
project deep down inside what they're
selling that I really want them a part
of it and so that was that was like kind
of like a gut call that I made and yeah
right right cuz the thing is that's
gonna live on in your film yeah yeah
yeah yeah you don't feel right about
right what makes sense yeah that makes
sense
I'm not tell you it was no no my mind is
going to all different places Wow yeah
see because you have to have integrity
that's the biggest thing it's like it's
like even though you're entrepreneur and
you think about you know the business
side of the film business and you still
have to have integrity and a vision you
know and that's the thing it's like you
can't sell out because if you sell out
what are you gonna do next such you know
it's funny cuz I just watched this
documentary on The Clash oh sure and so
it was like the because
Joe Strummer passed away I was like 16
years ago or something and I was looking
at all the comments and you know people
were just oh they sold out and they
became champagne social as well but who
wouldn't want to go to a certain level
though like III get kind of frustrated
with the whole sellout notion and I
realize that's a very indie argument
because there's commercial there's indie
there's the integrity of the creativity
it's funny because I don't look at it as
selling out I think it's a different way
of discovering your pain as an artist
because I think that all artists are
trying to overcome some sort of pain so
that they can be understood I know I am
someone really speaking to my own
experience but it's like you know you
give the clash as an example and I
wouldn't say they sold out they just
figured out a different way to display
their pain you know I mean they did have
they did have success meteoric success
mind you and in a form that wasn't even
a form yet you know a music form and I
mean you can say the Sex Pistols before
them but but did they get as much radio
play as the question no I mean the class
went international just out of the UK
but but at the same time it's just a
matter of like I just think that you
know who doesn't like champagne or
someone else's words not mine
yeah mind you I don't think they sold
out but yeah it was just so fascinating
did that that whole argument so yeah and
I know that especially in certain genres
that's a very touchy thing is selling
out in certain genres whether it's punk
rock or certain you know whatever style
well it's funny because like you're
growing up you know as a punk who we had
AB those people would call posers
oh sure you know those people that
thought they were and wanted to be but
they weren't true you know but then also
too it's like it's like it's like I've
got friends at our artists and and
our actors and musicians and and so
forth that feel like oh well they sold
out and I'm like what the hell does that
mean that they actually have some sort
of commercial success and you don't and
you're and you're jealous
you